Assassin's illegal street racing and a
heartwarming family film about old video
games it's time to run down the weakened
gaming here on Game life on Tuesday
October thirtieth many many games will
be released but the big one is of course
Assassin's Creed 3 after three games
playing as the silent killer Ezio in
Renaissance Italy we're finally going
somewhere new colonial America in which
we play rotten hi khatam a half British
half Native American who learns how to
love and how to hit things in the head
with a tomahawk it is time the setting
is the star of Assassin's Creed 3 it's
recreation of revolutionary America is a
sight to behold as for the game itself
well if you like the last few Assassin's
Creed games you'll like this if like me
you're getting some assassination
fatigue the gameplay doesn't really
change things up very much in this
installment there's a lot more combat
and a lot less sneaking and
assassinating than I would have liked on
the same day need for speed most wanted
hits stores while this is actually the
19th game in the long-running racing
series it's only the second to be
developed by criterion that's the studio
best known for burnout so if you enjoyed
the combination of racing other cars
while running from the cops embodied in
its 2010 game hot pursuit you will
likely also want to pick up most wanted
on Tuesday if all these new video games
are boring you how about some old ones
not one but two high-definition Pritikin
of last generations hot games are
scheduled to drop this week Capcom is
releasing okami HD a playstation 3
version of its gorgeous watercolor Zelda
style adventure as it download for
twenty bucks and Konami is packaging HD
remakes of the two games in the giant
robot action series zone of the enders
for the xbox 360 and the playstation 3
40 bucks if you were hoping for that
promise PlayStation Vita version of zone
of the enders it seems to have quietly
disappeared sorry finally on November
second there's a movie that old-school
gamers will want to go see especially if
they've got kids that they want to
indoctrinate I mean huh gently
introduced into the world of retro
Disney's latest animated feature
wreck-it Ralph stars a gaming bad guy
who just wants to be good I have seen
the film and the characters are charming
and funny the story is surprisingly
heartwarming and the jokes about old
games are pitch perfect go see this
movie that's it for this week in games
will see you on game life next week